foreign
welcome to the Ramsay show what's up
hey thank you Dave how you doing today
better than I deserve how can I help
hey thank you uh me and my wife are
going over our expenses last night and
got a little uh anyway upset over how
much we're spending so we decided we're
going to knock this last bit of debt out
we get with my bonus so I'm getting from
work
and then we'll be clear on the baby step
three
great the problem is is that right after
that happened found out that I am
eventually going to be laid off what
does eventually mean and
we may tell me when I'm being told I
will be laid off well I mean what do you
think is this a day a week a year
could be a couple months and but what I
do know is that after that I will have
60 days of notice in which I'll continue
to get paid
and after that 60 days of notice
I'll be getting 14 to 16 weeks of
severance pay awesome
now what do you make if I oh thank you
sir I make just my regular salary is 95.
what do you do
I'm an analytic consultant oh great
awesome well thank you okay so your
income's getting ready to go up and
you're going to get a new better job huh
that is yes absolutely yeah I mean you
weren't looking but they just told you
to
yes yes sir
so you need to land a job just in time
to get that big severance check
indeed that'd be great that's like a
signing bonus then right
yeah it would be for me yeah
um
but I figured that
in the worst case scenario
and it's not my goal at all but even at
the end of the reverence
should be able to put the if I paid off
the debt immediately
uh still have a six months uh expensive
savings after the end of the severance
if you're going to get a job
I know thank you no I mean really
There's jobs everywhere there's more
jobs than there I mean there's more jobs
than there are people looking for jobs
so I mean you got this is you're in
really good shape
thank you this is the best time to get
laid off
okay all right thank you for the support
no I'm I'm not making this up I mean
this is not support I'm I'm glad if you
were screwed Dave would tell you it also
happens to be the troops so you know
I don't know if you're in I don't know
if you're in Minneapolis at the end of
the story or not what's your wife work
what'd she make
all my life is unemployed we I'm the
head house okay that's cool all right
well you're in a field of analytics data
management
uh and so on that is hot hot very few
companies are going to exist if they
don't invest in your area over the
coming five years companies of size
anyway and so the the you are your
position is I mean it's deeply needed I
got I got three of those type things on
the board right here at Ramsey right now
so up I mean up for sale right now we're
trying to hire people so
um
uh data is just and analytics are just
if you can't do that in the future world
you're not going to be open and so
you're just you're sitting in a Sweet
Spot man and seriously you might roll
into 120 and pocket the severance as
your signing bonus you really might
I want you to start looking and I want
you to use everything Ken Coleman's got
have you heard of Ken have you heard
Ken's stuff yet
so uh to be fair uh honest you hired one
of my managers a couple years ago and
he's the greatest guy and
congratulations on you for ironing them
I don't know if I can say his name but
uh anyway he sent me a link to Ken
Coleman's uh
cool 150 questions who are you talking
about
Elliot Chambers oh God he's great you're
right yeah yeah that's awesome cool cool
yeah that's how that's amazing
yeah so what you mean get kids stuff get
the resume stuff I'll send you a copy of
paycheck to purpose Ken's book I want
you to read that and so here's the thing
I was just talking with a young guy this
morning that uh in this mentoring
session thing I was in and he was like
okay how do you get security if you're
working contract and I said everybody's
on contract baby
because you're a guy nobody's got
security except for your ability land on
your feet when they kick you out and you
got so much ability to land on your feet
that your security comes from your
ability not your stupid company
and that's why you're just in a Sweet
Spot man you're just you're rocking and
it's just going to turn out so good if
you'll plan it just a little bit and
know this
um if you're like me like most men we
put a lot of our self-worth into our job
and when somebody says hey we don't want
you to work for our company anymore it's
a it's a it's a gut punch
Ken and I have looked at some data
together where it losing your job
somebody calling you in and saying
you're fired
um re responds in your body as though
you lost a loved one
so it's like you're not crazy and you're
not weak you're not a wimp if you're not
a whiny baby like it hurts man when
somebody calls and says hey you're fired
and it sets off a terror alarm on our
body it should and then you get to fall
back on the data like Dave's telling me
and here's here's what here's what's
worse
they didn't even tell you that they said
we're going to tell you that later but
we don't know when yeah it's like dating
somebody and they're like I love you I'm
gonna break up with you later all right
I don't know when
yeah so I mean it's Terror they just
hung you out to dry but hey there you
know at least at least they dangled the
carrot of the severance to get you to
stick around a little while opportunity
opportunity opportunity Man by the way
if you get a really big signing bonus
tomorrow and 120 000 uh just pack your
desk and go
forget the severance
understood okay yeah so start looking
I'll send you a paycheck to purpose if
you can line it up for your start date
to be about the time they announce at
the new place
and unless there's enough money to leave
early uh you can get the severance as
your signing bonus out the door that's
going to be
freaking fun right there so yeah you see
you're in good shape yeah go ahead and
use your bonus money pay off your debt
pile money pile money pile money for
your emergency fund you got a big old
pile for an emergency fund and you got
the severance in the background and you
got Ken Coleman on your team getting you
moving thanks to Elliot and man you got
all the stuff you got all the stuff I
know how to do and so you're you know
you got your resume template you've got
uh you're going to start using your
proximity principle people you know who
how can you get connected to get your
foot in the door on this and Ken's going
to teach you every bit of that and
you're going to land a job in no time
your only problem might be that you land
it too soon and you you have to get the
quandary of whether to stick around long
enough to get the severance and uh that
might be a hard decision actually so but
just keep looking get out there get
moving hang on we'll uh have the guys
pick up and give you a copy of that book
and get you moving